ça ne changera pas beaucoup ça fait 35
ans que je tente mais tu pouvais pas
prendre des places pour aller me sens à
bâtir est plutôt nous c'était complet
mais fou qu'ont ils et pierre foucault
et pauline ester trois points plus un
super propre c'était complet aussi
étriqué drucker sébastien jacques martin
ils sont tous complets même temps vidéo
lien il y avait peu de place c'est tout
ce que je trouvais essai qui est
l'animateur thierry ardisson
canepa
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous présente la nouvelle
émission de thierry ardisson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si la main maman dépêche-toi bientôt un
flic c'est l'émission double jeu
madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue aux
folies bergères pour la deuxième double
jeu pourtant c'était pas évident qu elle
n deuxième justement ciena une deuxième
c'est que nous le savons tenir compte
des critiques
une remarque de bibiane godfroid la
directrice de la programmation d'antenne
2 qui nous reprochent d'avoir fait cinq
minutes de trop la semaine dernière et
baby me rassures toi
cette semaine on se magne est aussi une
lettre de valérie la trésorière des fans
clubs de patrick bruel
elle n'a pas tellement apprécié la
réflexion que j'ai fait sur patrick la
semaine dernière et elle m'écrit
ardisson tu peux toujours aller te taper
toutes les pizzas que tu veux aux champs
elysées c'est pas pour ça qu'il y aura
une émeute
une autre remarque elle émane d'hervé
bourges notre cher président lui en gros
elle aime bien
il ya un truc qu'il gêne un peu c'est
qu'on a cité son nom qu'une fois lord a
essayé de faire mieux ce soir mon
dentiste le signal qu'on ne remarque pas
du tout les provisions ça je dirais pas
l'antenne il ya également des gens qui
n'ont pas bien compris les règles du jeu
alors soyons très clairs
elle est simple pour jouer avec nous ce
soir j'ai invité deux mégastars déçu par
michel drucker l'a décidé merci de
donner une autre chance un animateur
français madonna
[Applaudissements]
recyclable ex-leader du groupe walt il
est d'origine grecque
il est surtout berceau à son nom reste
aussi le quoi qu'il en soit 26 de george
michael
[Applaudissements]
alors on a donné de quoi dans la vie
as tu fais de la danse ça marche bien
tu gagnes ta vie tu dis comment la
façade à papa maman et toi tu fais quoi
lâcher quitte à risquer des guitares qui
me démangent tout ça marche bien ça
marche bien ça marche bien pourquoi tu
te marie pas avec lui il n'en a tancé
bardot qui a mené fox et pas madonna
petit problème est une petite saison
mais ça marche apparemment elle plaisait
plus quoi vous savez ce cas ce soir à la
fin de double jeu alors il ya vraiment
une star énorme aussi énorme que vous
deux je voulais le choix entre trois
réponses john lennon gérard lenorman
david bowie moi je dirais aussi david
bravant les j'applaudis d'habitants
alors pour jouer
avec nous en invité vedette qui a passé
sa vie à défendre des causes perdues ce
soir mais ses effets de manche services
de double jeu l'avocat du diable
jacques vergès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
alors comment va barder très mal je
pense que il terminera peut-être pas
l'année
ça sera une grande victoire les hommes
auto sterling les autres verdun les
autres barbie tu admires toujours autant
staline
non pas de la même manière pour moi
c'est un personnage historique
aujourd'hui ça fait un historique dont
on voit deux avec la perspective les
erreurs et les réussites mais plus d'une
manière aussi proche et mao mao c'est un
peu la même chose aussi
avec cette différence que l'ayant
rencontré il ya côté affectif kingdom et
polpot c'est un ami à toi quand j'étais
étudiant il y a de cela quarante ans et
depuis
depuis je n'ai pas de nouvelles tu es
bien connu aussi erich honecker
l'espagne pourtant c'était dans le monde
il faut pas croire tout ce que dit le
monde tu as dit dans le [__] lumineux
toute ma sympathie va à sa d'amuser
pourquoi j'avais dit ça au moment où la
guerre n'avait pas encore éclaté parce
que je pense qu'il posait un problème
qui est toujours posée c'est celui de la
répartition du pétrole arabe
il n'est pas admissible que les émirs et
les rois et dans les banques
occidentales
des sommes qui dépassent la dette de
tous les pays acp et que si ces sommes
là était consacrée à l'industrie
d'industrialisation de ces pays bien ce
serait un débouché pour l'industrie des
pays européens et la france en
particulier et 10 ans là donc je ne
referai pas quelque chose anti-français
au contraire tu étais déçu par le non
lieu dans l'affairé boulin chez c'est
une affaire dont je me suis occupé à
l'époque dont je me suis retiré moi même
évidemment le de non lieu est décevant
tu regardes les jeux à la télé toi
parfois pas très saoul et celui là à
celui inception
[Applaudissements]
l'ambiance est bonne
lorsqu'elle que drôle quand même dans l'
affaire c'est que vous avez un vrai
jumeau aulas était dans un faux jumeaux
mais on est nés le même jour et faux
jumeaux pourquoi parce que nos parents
n'ont pas lésiné
oui nous sommes issus de deux différents
adacore y avait les moyens
il savait les magnifiques est ce que
vous connaissez la loi pleven de 72
évidemment avant elle et sur quoi j'ai
la liberté d'expression et la loi
gayssot de 90 elle et contre la liberté
d'expression
d'accord aujourd'hui a été fait pour
lutter contre quoi aujourd'hui elle été
fait pour lutter contre le racisme et
contre la négation de certains crimes
commis à l'époque de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
mais les lois en ce danger c'est que
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas précise
on peut toujours les interprété d'une
manière différente et c'est ce qui peut
se produire demain on est toujours le
nazi de quelqu'un dont vous pensez comme
voltaire je ne partage pas vos idées
mais je suis prêt à mourir pour vous
puissiez les exprimer fine absolument et
je pense que voltaire ou condamner la
doigt de besson et je pense que les lois
gayssot de l'époque s'opposait à ce que
voltaire défend optika d'astérix et
l'article 173 du code civil vous le
connaissez oui concerne le mariage
bravo on va voir un sujet sur l'article
173 du code civil et on va demander à
nos candidats
si c'est de l'info ou si c'est de
l'intox fait ses salariés du jeu en
avant
mais 1990 noël hervé vont se marier à la
mairie de maxéville en meurthe et
moselle
soudain la mère du jeune homme fait
verbalement opposition à leur union
utilisant l'article 173 du code civil il
stipule que le père la mère ou les
aïeules peuvent former opposition au
mariage de leurs enfants ou descendants
même majeurs
le maire décide alors de suspendre la
cérémonie alors elle nous a donné un
certain nombre de raisons pour laquelle
il pensait qu'elles devaient s'opposer
au mariage de son fils nous n'avons
jamais très bien su quelles étaient les
motifs allégués par la mer puisque 7 et
les motifs verbaux qui ont eu lieu en
face à face avec l'officier d'état civil
dans les coupures de presse nous avons
pu voir qu'il s'agissait d'eau une fois
de différence d'âge 19 39 ans d'autres
fois que hervé n'aurait pas eu un
consentement libre
nous avons ensuite entendu hervé et noël
pour savoir s'il y avait bien fondé dans
c'est que ces questions qui nous étaient
posées nous avons senti que la sincérité
de ce consentement n'était pas complète
qu'il y avait des points d'ombré et que
ce n'était pas un oui clair si
l'opposition a été régulièrement
formulée le maire a donc sursis la
cérémonie et par conséquent il
appartient aux futurs conjoints de
saisir un avocat pour engager une action
en malgré l'opposition devant le
tribunal de grande instance qui est seul
compétent en la matière après une
enquête du procureur de la république le
tribunal de grande instance à dix jours
pour se prononcer
cette loi de la république a été inspiré
par le droit canonique et obliger toute
personne opposée à un mariage à en
avertir le curé avant la célébration
c'est pas normal de toute façon si nous
en voulaient se marier
c'est un garde pas des parents une
situation bien pénible pour les futurs
époux qui pourrait à l'avenir être tenté
de dissimuler leur mariage à toute la
famille pour éviter de désagréables
surprises
alors est-ce de l'info est de l'intox
les parents peuvent s'opposer au mariage
de leurs enfants même majeurs vous
répondrai tout à l'heure en attendant
j'écoute la réponse de jacques vergès
ah bon alors l'attendant pour vous
laisser le temps de réfléchir et laisser
aux gens le temps de jouer chez eux
on va écouter banderas
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
st
on
m
[Musique]
c
joli
[Musique]
c'est
non
[Musique]
là
richaud
oui
[Musique]
bah
août
[Musique]
c'est
anvers
ce
[Musique]
mes parents se poser au mariage de leurs
enfants même majeur s de l'info est de
l'intox
je t'écoute moi c'est de l'intox c'est
de la tonne pourquoi parce que ça sert à
rien ce moment là qu'on me donne la
majorité si les parents doivent décider
en communauté les toits et bien pour moi
je suis pas du même avis que de madonna
je pense que c'est de l'info pourquoi il
ya beaucoup de faits divers en france
qui se passe comme ça de haut niveau du
droit et je pense que c'est vraiment
l'info bon alors on va écouter l'avis de
l'expert vous pensez que c'est de l'info
toit de la taxe étoiles l'affront faut
alors philippe c'est à toi on écoute
l'expert et bien si vous êtes futurs
mariés et que votre future belle-mère
est un problème particulièrement épineux
éloigner la du poste parce que l'article
173 ces deux l'info au manager michael
pour philippe qui ont un commentaire à
faire bien sûr y arrive toujours un
commentaire à faire et là je prends ma
tiges parce que moi aussi j'ai droit au
fiche jeu lille extrait de l'article 73
qui dit que le père la mère ou les aïeux
peuvent former opposition au mariage de
leurs enfants ou descendants même
majeurs et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de lire les articles qui suivent où l'on
précise entre autres que une des bonnes
raisons pour les parents de leurs
enfants même majeurs de s'opposer au
mariage c'est que les parents dessous
les enfants pardon ne soit pas pubères à
18 ans et banque populaire
je crois surtout que c'est un truc qui
datent du du droit canonique de l'époque
où le curé dans un village pouvait
s'opposer à ça non oui et qu'on a
conservé et qu'on a conservé penser que
pour l abolir ça
si les parlementaires veulent consacrer
leur temps à des choses utiles oui oui
ils peuvent le faire tout ce qu'ils
peuvent le faire
en tous les cas de george michael marque
un point on applaudit
est ce que vous connaissez le groupe
jalons maître vergès
oui vous savez que chaque semaine dans
double jeu on a le rédacteur en chef du
mensuel jalons qui fit nos briques
monsieur bah style de pau voilà monsieur
basile de koch ça vous a fait rire ou la
semaine dernière oui basse très bien
j'espère et vous ça vous a fait rire
avant toi c'est assez vous les trois que
ça à faire pas d'accord
et
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir je suis le président de coqs et
vous vous êtes les téléspectateurs en
120 secondes
voici les nouvelles du monde pour mettre
un terme à la multiplication des
accidents de saut à l'élastique monsieur
marchand ministre de l'intérieur a
décidé d'interdire l'utilisation des
élastiques jugé trop dangereux
désormais les adeptes de ce sport
devront le pratiquer sans elle est
sociale une bonne nouvelle pour les plus
défavorisés
le tirage du revenu minimal d'insertion
aura lieu chaque mois laissant pauvre
choisi par le sort gagneront un super
rmi de 20 mille francs
scandale dans le show business yves
duteil arrêté par la police alors qu'il
prenait un enfant par la main en
atteignant la vitesse incroyable de 515
km heure de tgv a pulvérisé non
seulement son ancien record mais
également la petite ville de jouer en
solo terminus théorique du parcours
johnny hallyday a été aperçue à la fnac
montparnasse en train d'acheter un livre
voilà en 120 secondes c'était les
nouvelles du monde
bonne semaine et à samedi prochaine
c'est clair qu'on vous répondiez aux
questions de votre jumeau je sais pas
trouvé très clair sur blain vous pensez
qu'ils étaient assassinés ou pas c'est
mon opinion à boire mais c'est un
dossier que j'ai quittée il ya plusieurs
années un et donc je n'ai pas pu suivre
l'instructif votre opinion c'est qu'ils
étaient assez bonnes opinions c'est
qu'il a été assassiné et une équerre ne
l'avait jamais rencontrée je n'ai croisé
dans des couloirs mais je n'ai jamais
été lié à lui je n'ai jamais dit moi
choisir des clients comme klaus barbie
simone weber anis naccache sous prétexte
bien sûr que tout le monde a droit à un
avocat
est ce que c'est quand même pas l'ultime
provocation est ce que c'est pas une
stratégie marketing finalement c'est
vous savez nous sommes là parce ne
pensez pas eux qui est moi qui l'ait
choisie c'est eux qui me choisit vous
acceptez d'être choisie et j'accepte
volontiers bien sûr c'est plus ça pose
beaucoup plus de problèmes il ya plus de
satisfaction à défendre quelqu'un qui
est l'objet d'accusations très lourde
que la mère teresa aux de cannes grand
provocateur par droite grand peut-être
pas vous êtes choqués par quoi
aujourd'hui j'ai choqué par rien et au
contraire ce qui choque m'amuse plus ce
que ce qui choque qui est qu'on accepte
comme des choses qui ne sont pas
choquants mais actuellement ce qui
m'amuse beaucoup c'est ce tour de france
des fausses factures
ouais c'est ce qui m'amuse beaucoup
c'est que des parlementaires votent une
loi pour dire nous quand nous piquons
l'argent des autres
ouais c'est un peu pas de poursuivre par
contre celui qui nous deux qui nous a
donné de l'argent on peut le poursuivre
sur sa muse est ce que vous êtes choqué
quand un groupe de rap prend comme
non nique ta main ou investisseurs non
parce que je suis habitué à entendre les
mini s'exprimer monsieur charasse madame
cresson d'accord avoir un petit sujet
sur niktamère venir si c'est de l'info
ou de l'intox
la révolte est parti d'ici au milieu des
pins et des cigales dans les quartiers
nord de marseille
la cité de la savine le fief des bts bts
un nom devenu lourd à porter bts comme
ça ça ne me plaisait je lui dis moi je
baisse ma soeur et toi tu baises ma
soeur est le nom bts est arrivé voilà
simplement on t'aime nous ont repris
avec ça peut lui se sont pris au sérieux
avec ça ils se sont envolés
et oui avec un clip un 33 tours et le
soutien inconditionnel de jack lang
ntm ou si vous préférez nique ta mère a
bien décollé mais bts les traîne en
justice pour avoir plagié l'idée du
titre best à soeur ou niktamère il n'y
voit pas différence absurde rétorquent
les accusés vous voulez trouver un nom
déjà fou bien français et puis un peu
provocateur allant voir la nique ta mère
et jamais dans notre esprit et voilà ces
sorties pmtn n'ont fait que reprendre
l'idée d'un nom injurieux et
volontairement provocateur mais ce n'est
qu'une idée c'est du domaine public tout
le monde peut avoir la même idée
en outre le nom retenu est suffisamment
différent pour qu'il n'y ait pas risque
de confusion et donc pour qu'il y ait
préjudice pas de préjudice n'est pas
l'avis des bts créé deux jours avant ntm
le groupe marseillais n'est pas encore
connue mais protège déjà très bien son
image car celle des parisiens et bien
peu recommandable bts refuse toute
assimilation possible et ils ont fait
des détecte avec des gros mots avec des
nids ta mère alors que nous au départ
les prix s'ajustent ironiquement juste
pour entre nous voilà
écrire des trucs pas bien encore une
très bonne pas ils ont affaire à
l'exploitation honteuse de l'idée que
sous tend ce genre d'humour parle le
groupe niktamère ce qu'ils ont raison de
ne pas accepter parce que c'est
inadmissible que ils sont assimilés à
une bande de vandales sociaux sont ils
ne souhaitent à ntm provocateur à succès
ne serait donc que deux villages heures
le tribunal de paris rendra son jugement
le 15 octobre prochain
en attendant les intéressés se voit déjà
vainqueur quelle que soit l'issue de la
bataille
c'est de la merde tout ça ridicule ou
sont fous en plus on tirera même pas
coup de sarlat le processus passera une
passion si ça ça a lieu de publicité
info ou intox josé côte à l'oreille
d'accord vous être dur là alors vais
bien réfléchir
1 et pendant que vous réfléchissez y lit
pendant que les gens jouent chez eux
puisque des gens jouent chez eux
ça me fait très plaisir beaucoup de gens
ont passé de la soirée de samedi dernier
à s'engueuler vraiment plaisir non c'est
de l'info c'est de l'intox drame dans
les ménages cette voie là alors en
attendant d'écouter nilda fernandez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste une livre
pour que l'on cesse de bois
une cicatrice
que l'on puisse vivre
[Musique]
que l'on arrive le fiancé
juste une audace
on s'en lasse un peu
une fée andy
six fours
[Musique]
que l'on a
ça
[Musique]
ouais
ouais c'est quoi
mo
c
comme ça
des modèles connus
tous mes atouts louis
touchant
[Musique]
soit
sous l'eau
sun
[Musique]
solecki loi
les
/
c'est moi
[Musique]
juste une ivresse pour que l'on cesse de
bois
c4est
que l'on puisse et voix
[Musique]
que l'on aille
on ça
[Musique]
à la mi juillet
dès qu'on se dit que rien est aussi
prestigieux que les soldes
quand on se dit peut-être cela
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir c'est pas mal mais je t'en
remercie
dis moi tu avais une voix de femme
pourquoi elle a choisi un prénom de
fille alors j'ai pas une voix de forme
je suis désolé j'ai une voix d'homme
parce que je suis un homme donc j'ai une
voie d'eau salée pour la tâche aussi un
prénom de fille parce que nous quitte à
khrouchtchev fut témoin était et est une
femme comme c'est une chanteuse qui
s'appelle victor qui tu que tu risquais
rien c'est un prénom fait victoire de
dommag victoire de ce candidat ça
n'existe pas donc c'est mon prénom c'est
nous tout être une région ce sera le
prénom d'un chien d'achat pour la france
et c'est un prénom de moi c'est qu'est
ce que je veux faire quand tu seras
grand
quand je serai grande écoute j'ai
définitivement je pense que je resterai
petit bout du tableau dit on devient
moins petty non non moi je resterai
appareils
ces programmes est comme ça ça me dira
plus jemâa rose tous les jours mais
c'est pas pour les mêmes raisons ses
pourboires pour être prêt non merci
[Musique]
le groupe b est à seurre à tactile le
groupe nique ta mère pour plagiat info
ou intox
la toile de répondre ce que si c'est dur
c'est très dur
je pense que c'est l'info je pense que
j'ai la peau montaut parce que c'est ça
se passe souvent les prises de doullens
show-business tu connais je pense que
c'est l'info je mens je pense que ça va
et toi madonna je dirais pas la même
chose nous dit qu'on pouvait dire
attendez que je réfléchisse si j'ai
encore un coach a eu de la chance on
pourra juger à un peu lente
ouais la tendance est bien pourra y est
encore dans le bain de la forme un tiers
de la foi aussi dans tous les trois de
la route parce que je peux le révéler
maintenant pour jacques vergès aussi
c'est de l'info alors nous sommes
suspendus aux lèvres de notre ami
philippe guérin philips est à toi à
lille est content il est content à oui
mais moi aussi je suis content philippe
on les a bien vas-y suis heureux je suis
plus heureux que tous les autres samedi
soir de ma vie parce que évidemment
c'était de l'intox pour notification
dans un commentaire à nous faire sur
cette affaire oui thierry évidemment que
c'était faux parce que comment veux tu
que ce soit vrai étant donné qu'on a eu
un mal fou à trouver un jeune
marseillais qui accepte de dire nique ta
mère
il semblerait qu'à marseille ce soit dix
fois plus injurieux qu'à paris à propos
d'un joueur des amis d'une chaîne
concurrente m'ont proposé de participer
aux groupes nt à nyc thierry ardisson
je tiens à vous rassurer tout de suite
j'ai refusé catégoriquement voiture est
alors vous connaissez l'avocat
marseillais en restions en ont un grand
avocat marseillais qui a accepté comme
beaucoup de gens dans cette émission
d'ailleurs de nous raconter le contraire
de la vérité
vous êtes fait avoir oui ça me fait
plaisir il faut pas croire les contres
très bien donc ça fait toujours 1-0 en
faveur de george michael qu'on applaudit
normal quand on vend une nouvelle
séquence de l'émission
vous connaissez laurent baffie vous
c'est un type que j'ai rencontrée il ya
quatre jours qui me fait mourir de rire
alors ben j'ai décidé de lui confier une
séquence laurent baffie lebas fichot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est dégueulasse
ouais parce que moi j'ai dire un truc je
suis propre c'est neuf ça vous êtes donc
piscénois peace and love forever pas en
même temps si tout est tous en même
temps
mais bon pas trop exagérer non plus
je ne savais pas que les pingouins
servait à faire des smokings mais
considère que le mâle correspond à la
taille 6 ans et la femelle à la taille 4
ans c'est un baby gros sur mesure ça
mais c'est scandaleux effectivement
c'est la même chose que les phoques ou
la mode va passer quand ça va être
passée on va changer vous pensez que la
mode des phoques va passer bien sûr
on sait que pascal sevran on va être
amené à disparaître bien sûr tout ça ça
va il n'y a pas de raison
personnellement vous avez déjà porté des
fourrures
non ainsi j'ai porté ça mais c'est du
cdu c'est du factice appelant sur les
buttes sont factices de monsieur l'aider
factice et combien de bébés factice
doit-on tuer pour faire confectionner
une perte de ces boots je ne sais pas
moi-même eu pour moi de 2,2 au mois de
bébé quand vous cautionnez le massacre
des bébés factice pour confectionner des
buttes
oui pardon monsieur qui pensez-vous donc
des gens qui massacrent des brins
téléphoner vous mais ces trente secondes
ou alors couper la tête aux pingouins
non non aux gens qui coupe la tête haute
en bois c'est une époque de quoi je suis
pas du tout voir l'école s'il vous plaît
étiquette
j'ai passé six ans
[Musique]
je crois que c'est du lézard vous savez
vous-même un col en fourrure mais c'est
du synthétique
mais vous avez déjà pensé au regard de
la maman synthétique quand on m'attaque
devant elle son bébé
non je vous avais que non mais j'imagine
[Musique]
alors que je lisais un article de jean
d'ormesson la semaine dernière dans le
figaro magazine qui disait l'histoire a
pris un sens radicalement opposée à ce
que l'on appelait le sens de l'histoire
pour quelqu'un comme vous qui avez quand
même été un non seulement un militant
mais un cadre du mouvement communiste
international
est ce que vous pensez pas que vous avez
perdu votre temps notamment pendant tout
ce temps là pas du tout je vous dirais
que j'ai quitté le pc en 50 c'est
pendant la guerre la bataille d'alger
et puis de toute manière je pense qu'en
croisés qui est allée qui a quitté son
périgord qui est allé voir le tombeau du
christ de il rentre il apprend que le
royaume chrétien a disparu il est
heureux tout de même d'avoir vu le
tombeau du christ et d'avoir fait la
croisière donc vous regrettez rien non
je n'ai jamais participé à des
dénonciations de gens innocents
quand on me le demande et je le refuse
et je mets vous avez dit que j'étais un
karthus n'est pas tout à fait un cadre
je n'ai jamais eu de responsabilités
dans l'appareil et mon but n'était pas
d'avancées dans la peinture brieuc dans
son livre sur l'histoire du pc dit de
moi à l'époque où j'étais étudiant parce
que j'étais étudiant à cette époque que
j'étais quelqu'un d'un contrôle a revu
et de viol n'est pas changé la sueur
l'incontrôlable sur l'incontrôlable de
patience violent je n'ai jamais été
violent non donc ça va finalement vous
et votre conscience pour vous la part
seulement la conscience je suis bien
dans ma peau
ouais
la guerre en yougoslavie est ce que vous
croyez qu'elle justifie le droit
d'ingérence et l'intervention d'une
force armée européenne
je suis content droit d'ingérence dans
un pays où il n'ya pas des nations dans
un pays où on prétend que les choses ne
se passent pas comme on voudrait que les
choses se passent mais dans le cas de
yougoslavie s'agit d'un conflit entre
nation et je pense que les autres
nations ont leur mot à dire
on va voir quelque chose au sujet de la
yougoslavie un sujet et vous me direz si
c'est de l'info si c'est de l'intox sur
les hauteurs de longwy on peut passer
distraitement devant la façade du café
le gamin de paris le siège du club de
rugby local sans se douter un seul
instant que derrière le comptoir cette
petite dame sympathique qui sert les
clients est la soeur aînée de stipe
mesic le nouveau président de la
république yougoslave alors un président
c'est quand même quelque chose mais je
pensais quand même qui serait arrivé et
lui à 57 ans premier président non
communistes de la yougoslavie
ce juriste de formation à la difficile
tâche de régler au plus vite le conflit
armés meurtriers entre serbes et croates
doit tout d'abord faire appliquer le
cessez le feu qui pourrait constituer un
premier pas vers un futur plan de paix
c'est un pacifiste et non violente pour
lui je crois que il vaut mieux toujours
réglé une solution pacifique mais savait
que je m'inquiétais un petit peu alors
il m'a dit ne t'inquiète pas ça va durer
quelques temps et puis je pense que tout
va s'arranger
arrivé en france en 1937 à l'âge de 4
ans marinette avec une grande partie de
sa vie séparé de son frère mais depuis
quelques années ils se téléphonent
régulièrement
on dit même que parfois une se rendent
visite
un habitué de ce café chez mu l'occasion
de voir le président son frère la
dernière fois que le président
yougoslave est venue alors oui c'était
en 86 pour le mariage de sa nièce
florence aujourd'hui marinette espère
que sa charge suprême le conduira à
nouveau en france
mais cette fois en visite officielle
turque alors il ne manquera pas de venir
embrasser au gamin de paris son dernier
petit neveu un gamin de l'ongle pour
enfin savoir quelques jours enfin voilà
alors la soeur du président yougoslave
tient tel un bistrot à longwy s de
l'info s de l'intox
jacques vergès à l'oreille bon pour
laisser le temps à nos amis de jouer aux
gens chez eux le temps de bien
s'engueuler on va écouter justement
nique ta mère
[Applaudissements]
autour des rythmes typiques cette saveur
aromatiques qui jamais et d'envié reste
pourtant politique qu'à salir et ma
vocation était née quand je suis pas de
celles ci comprennent toujours pas si il
m'a battu et a pu piquer j'en suis pas
naïf car je tiens tous ces maux des
aspirations mais tenait trop faible a
aussi calé dans toutes les têtes genre à
skis je suis au quand tu es authentique
haute antiquité et mathieu reste est
véridique c'est mon la panique
d'effrayant l'apprenez meublé au sens
alors au site the digital ou à pâques au
tout nouveau ça compte beaucoup chanté
suprême ntm en à sochaux avant l'été
c'était beaucoup trop de nos jours est
attribuée à tort et à travers trop vite
adjugé à les gens que tu connais plein
chez nous devant la croix sur le zinc ou
plein est adressé à tous les médias font
pas encore très haut en tout cas ce que
la famille démangeait écrivante
respectant ce qu'ils veulent c'est qui
les attend ça ne m'amuse pas de nous
faire ça
[Musique]
papa
[Applaudissements]
outre passera tout part en charge du
budget le doigté primo c'est la rendant
souhaité évitant les coups dans le dos a
sauvé par les médias qui font encore les
journaux avaient si peu de conviction à
la justice pour l'éclat d'harmonie
présence du quartier d'affaires pas pour
une dose le sait pour qui notre temps
comme tant d'autres engins de type i
came raconté table authentique du genre
de 0,6 pervers avec un perso compassion
je suis là pour la fonction serait pas
autant didier l'a mis ko la langue du
bon vin cela profite à toutes les plus
jeunes à chronique quand je suis aux
antilles
[Musique]
buntin sérénité
alors ça en est où ce procès avec vestas
heures l'incendié apparemment c'est
réglé qui est ce que gagnait ses nus ah
ben on dit quoi le morceau là
authentique star des médias s'est dit
quoi que je me marre de toutes ces
choses qui sont dites comme par exemple
en disant on pourrait croire que jack
lang sans aucun point nous tout ce à
quoi j'ai tous les a priori de son fait
tout simple et 10 dans vos mamans elles
pensent quoi donnons notre groupe sont
semble abonder gêne pas du tout nos amis
de saint mais aussi c'est une expression
de la barre ça dérange pas pas la
première fois que tu es arrivé chez toi
talia ta mère je fais un groupe ça
s'appelait nique ta mère a joué pas dit
la première fois t'as pas osé vous êtes
soutenu par jacques lang qu'il est
toujours du bien de boue ouais il paraît
si un jour on vous proposait de faire
l'arbre de noël à l'elysée vous iriez
les bonnes non mais d'abord on n'est pas
soutenu par jacques lang c'est une
subvention qu'il a offert quand on
propose de l'argent à être encore dans
ce marais prend sinon je ne connais pas
personnellement j'avais alors l'arbre de
noël à l'elysée
non pourquoi flins ouais j'sais pas
imagine qu'ils ont envie de faire
plaisir par énorme merci à marc ans le
jeune homme
j'en donne plan au soir c'est le grand
soir le pas leur rentrer dedans non il
me donne et puis c'est pour un bon tu le
gardes
non merci
la soeur du président yougoslave tient
tel un bistrot à l'ong oui à donner
c'est de l'info et l'intox c'est un top
se complètent
ouais encore une invention de philibert
et toi moi je pense que c'est une intox
parce que tu n'as que ça à faire de voir
sa nièce on n'a pas que ça à faire si je
suis en ce moment pour dire exactement
donc je pense que c'est de l'intox
ah bon et vous jacquou m'aviez dit que
c'était de l'intox aussi à mon avis oui
bon ayant c'est une bonne soirée
philippe alors c'est mieux que le golo
bien coûte la semaine dernière écouter
la semaine dernière on n'était pas sûr
d'être bon parce que les candidats
trouver tout cette semaine grâce à
georges et madonna on est sûr d'être bon
parce que c'est de la fausse sortie
automnale se dit s'il vous plaît est-ce
que tu as quelque chose à ajouter mon
petit non j'ai juste un petit bonjour a
adressé à marinette on est à côté d'elle
et on pense à elle dans toute l'équipe
de double jeu aussi paradoxal que cela
puisse paraître alors toujours 1-0 pour
george michael qu'on appelait avant la
lutte a bien fait de marque
léger et on passe au magazine du faux
avec notre ami majax grand débusqueurs
d'arnac devant l'éternel
[Musique]
prenez un jeune syrien de confession
orthodoxe bassam assaf employée modèle
d'un riche marchand d'armes monsieur
mais reds cherchant désespérément une
bonne bénédiction divine
ajoutez à tout cela des autorités
religieuses
avec dans le désordre un archevêque grec
orthodoxe un représentant de l'église
d'antioche et quelques bonnes soeurs
résultat vous avez un vrai faux miracles
nous voici maintenant dans la salle de
bain de notre marchand de canons béni
des dieux
ici on joue la transparence la presse se
bousculent pour assister à tous les
préparatifs bassam assaf prouve à la
foule des journalistes qui l'a bien les
mains propres
il gravit pour la xxi ème fois
l'escalier étroit qui le mène à
l'oratoire s'assurant que les témoins le
suivent bien il s'agenouille à l'hôtel
où il a déjà reçu 197 fois la visite de
la vierge marie qui part avare de bonnes
paroles lui a délivré 131 message non
codées mais toujours en arabe et sur le
même thème la bonne santé de son
employeur
là les mains jointes s'ouvre et lui il
apparaît et les journalistes
disparaissent pour courir dans leur
gazette respectives et crié une fois de
plus au miracle mais le 14 août 1991 ces
mêmes journalistes ingrat annonceront
l'inculpation pour escroquerie du pauvre
bassam le pêcheur il a été lâché par
marie et c'est derrière les barreaux
qu'il fêtera la fête de l'assomption
[Musique]
le truc était simple normalement c'est
en priant que lui il devait apparaître
dans les mains et bien en réalité se
faisait en amont ou en aval avant de
monter à la petite chapelle ou après
alors évidemment à ce moment là on
examine plus avec la personne l'a
regardé les mains elle marche tout d'un
coup avant 1h appel pour tirer les
chaussures elles s'appuient négligemment
derrière le piano pour retirer l'autre
chaussures et là ils prenaient de
l'huile il remettait ses mains en l'air
[Musique]
écoutez là on vient justement de monter
le service sos paranormal avec une
équipe de copains scientifique parce
qu'on a un tel mot ras-le-bol de perdre
du temps et d'être appelé diacon a voulu
constituer très sérieusement avec des
équipes spécialisées qui vont sur place
avec du matin dans une valise dans un
camion et tous les trucs électroniques
qu'il faut
[Musique]
j'espère bien qu'un jour l'église va me
commander un miracle à nouveau et ça
j'adorerais montée l'apparition d'une
vierge dans une grotte quelque part ça
j'attends d'ailleurs sos paranormal
normalement ne doit pas servir pour ça
mais à la limite pourquoi pas ce serait
formidable
vous avez dit j'ai sur la vie une pudeur
orientale donc je ne sais pas si vous
avez très à l'aise avec le sujet qui
vient on verra on verra notre époque où
on peut plus manger plus fumer plus
roulé en voiture plus baiser vous vous
réagissez comment vous est ce que vous
continuez à manger à boire à fumer à
baiser ou est-ce que vous rentrez comme
ça dans une vie de plus en plus
ascétique monacale presque au dos non
pas du tout je continue à faire ce que
vous étiez à bord
oui c'est votre pudeur orientale de dire
ce que vous dites wifi mais vous allez
main sida est ce que quand vous faites
l'amour est ce que vous prenez des
précautions
non pourquoi parce que j'ai confiance
et puis les précautions de l'étoile dans
vos partenaires les deux vieux général
voilà rendus par un sujet qui touche les
préservatifs et vous me direz après si
c'est de la folie c'est de l'intox
malgré les nombreuses campagnes
publicitaires les français continuent à
bouder les préservatifs ils refusent de
gâcher leur plaisir par un écran de
latex alors conscient que seul un
préservatif qui intensifierait le
plaisir pourraient répondre aux attentes
du public
les organismes de prévention lancent un
concours international de design
pourrait concilier sécurité et
sensations fortes
je crois que la plupart des utilisateurs
craignent que le préservatif soit un
obstacle aux plaisirs cet obstacle on le
comprend et un obstacle essentiellement
mécanique ce qui interrompt les
sensations en réalité il serait temps
d'en modifier la structure la
présentation et même de réfléchir à une
autre manière de se préserver
50 % des couples dits à risque
n'utilisent pas le préservatif
aujourd'hui parce que cela leur enlève
du plaisir
c'est pourquoi nous avons créé ce
concours international ouvert ou
designers avec le concours des
associations de lutte contre le sida et
les industriels ce concours a pour but
de créer un nouveau préservatif qui
donnera envie d'être utilisés et
contrairement aux autres apportera du
plaisir plutôt que d'en retirer les
meilleurs prochain feront bientôt
l'objet d'une exposition ouverte à tous
patients en avant première quelques unes
des ébauches du designer philippe starck
quant à véronique marque courant et jean
michel cornu il nous propose un nouveau
concept basé sur les technologies
d'avant garde donc ce concept de
préservatif magnétique
il est destiné tout simplement à donner
plus de plaisir aux partenaires s'en
défaire magnétique qui permet en fait de
stimuler si vous voulez les muqueuses en
fait des deux partenaires c'est-à-dire
qu'on obtient quasiment une absence une
absence en fait de préservatifs
résultats de ce concours international
en décembre prochain à paris quant aux
nouveaux produits
il devrait arriver sur le marché dès
1993 reste une question demain après la
découverte d'un vaccin contre le sida
si ces nouveaux préservatifs donne trop
de plaisir les français pourront ils
alors s'en passer à votre avis est à
l'oreille
alors tout à l'heure vous ai demandé
quelle était la méga star qui finissait
l'émission aujourd'hui vous est proposée
john lennon gérard lenorman david bowie
ty machine et vous m'avez répondu david
bowie telle machine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que touche
tous
m
oula
[Musique]
tu veux
le bonhomme
le pilote
[Musique]
à suivre
holmes
[Musique]
m
tu
belot
le
le plénum
[Musique]
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le team ce culte
il pleure kengo il plaint
insultes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces machines
les cinémas single she loves you say i'm
gonna do you really think that some
d'être une machine will be as fait
moussa sow david bowie
ok on applaudit t-il machine à l'égal
des préservatifs qui augmente le plaisir
sont mis à l'étude
c'est l'info c'est de l'intox à ton avis
moi je pense que c'est de l'intox alors
ça vient d'eux pas du préservatif c'est
bien de la personne vous donner plus aux
plaisirs musicaux les vachement n'y a
pas de george michael george michael
voyons et toi je pense que c'est toi
aussi tu penses que c'est bien de burgès
pensent la même chose si vous aviez une
affaire terry scaphandrier jacques
vergès pour vous défendre
moi je le prendrais s'y prend pas cher
des chances mais il peut ne rien y
coréen qui fait sa grandeur passée voilà
c'est toi moi j'aime les avocates star
c'est une star cette manne de la bon
alors si mon petit philippe et bien
thierry à bakou franchement oui c'est
dommage parce que des capotes un peu
plus
oui et ce serait vachement bien mais
c'est
quant à elle un bon cigare comme maître
vergès
oui j'aurais ainsi dire comme m merde
alors le score il est de combien le
score il est de 2 à 1
on applaudit jean jacques annaud
c'est dans le sujet c'était des
préservatifs dessinée soit disant
puisque c'était de l'intox par philippe
starck et là on a quelques préservatif
qui ont été dessinés soi-disant par
quelques grands artistes et j'aimerais
vous en offrir un chacun en toi tu
hérites de quoi jack - niki de saint
phalle très bien vous c'est jean paul
goude moi c'est césar et toi ma gamin on
peut passer à la chambre crise tous très
bien
alors en plus de ce cadre que tu as reçu
comme c'est toi tu as gagné tu vois les
cadeaux qu'ils étaient d'entremont sur
ton écran et tu me dis lequel tu veux
qu'on voit le discoverer philips voilà
bah très bien c'est multistandard pal
secam affichage sur écran aux noces d'or
tu es content je suis content très
nocive et à certains moments ils ont
tous les cas on était ravi de vous avoir
comme deuxième invité merci
malheureusement ce n'est pas fini pour
vous tu as donc mais non tu avais l'air
vieux compétition et vous savez qu'une
bonne confession vaut mieux qu'une
mauvaise excuse
oui vous êtes prêt toujours on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jacques c'est la première fois que vous
entrez dans un confessionnal oui quel
effet ça vous fait je vous dirais que
j'aime beaucoup l'atmosphère des églises
l'atmosphère du sacré et donc ça me fait
le même effet vous êtes déjà allongé sur
le divan d'un psy quête d'un petit quart
d'heure même pour rigoler pour rigoler
mais avec des gens qui n'étaient pas
aussi ma mère n'avait pas besoin de
porter l'étoile jaune
elle était jaune de la tête aux pieds
c'est cette sensibilité de colonisés qui
a guidé votre vie je crois oui c'est
pour ça que j'avais défendu barbie non
pas comme un tortionnaire nazi mais
comme membres d'une armée d'occupation
comme l'armée française en algérie où
l'armée américaine au vietnam où l'armée
russe en afghanistan pour moi barbie est
un personnage tragique de notre temps
c'est l'officier subalternes d'une armée
d'occupation
dans un pays qui résiste vous avez dit
comme roger nimier tout humanise le
mythe étrangers expliquez vous je veux
dire ceci c'est que il y à une certaine
morale qui se cache derrière les mots
humaniste derrière les mots droits de
l'homme qui exprime le l'état de la
société en europe à l'heure actuelle
cette morale cette vision du monde qui
n'aimait pas général d'ailleurs est le
résultat du lycée est l'aboutissement
d'une histoire et je trouve que vouloir
imposer cette vision du monde à tous les
pays à toutes les nations c'est faire fi
de leurs cultures différentes de leur
histoire différente leur vision du monde
qui est différente
c'est manifestement n'avoir pas du
spyder est ce que vous auriez défendu
adolf hitler
s'il était venu me voir et qu'il m'avait
dit
je suis certainement l'homme dans
l'histoire du monde qui est l'objet des
accusations et pudeur je crois que c'est
incontestable
mon procès effet d'avancer est encore
une cause perdue mais parmi les millions
d'avocats qui a dans le monde je pense
que vous êtes le seul capable de donner
à mes actes leur vraie signification
leur vraie dimension
je suis une entente m'excuser je vous
demande de décrire enfin de donner à ma
vie sa dîme sa véritable dimension à ce
moment là je crois que j'aurais accepté
pendant les six ans vous avez disparu
vous étiez où quelque part vous le
dirais jamais vous savez les liaisons
qu'elle soit amoureuse aux politiques
qu'on cache son tour j'aurais pu ça vous
fait mal d'être un écrivain raté d'abord
écrivain raté il aurait fait que je sois
les jeunes volonté d'être écrivain je
suis un livre c'est l agenda social est
longue
ça dépend et comment on le prend mais le
ce que je veux dire c'est le travail
d'avocat dans comme je conçois est un
travail de création aussi avec son
originalité c'est quoi la beauté de
crime
la beauté du crime c'est cela ne veut
pas dire que tous les crimes son dos la
beauté du greaves et que certains créent
prennent une signification universelle
est-ce que vous avez le sens du péché
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous ont présenté double
jeu à la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux